okay let's update you on the indy gogo
fundraiser at david pakman.com slash
donate which we are running to really
expand not only the david pakman show
but progressive activism at large we
have a new high water mark for the top
donation to our indiegogo campaign
before yesterday uh two hundred ninety
nine dollars was the top donation we
actually had to two hundred ninety nine
dollar donations we now have a new
leader that has emerged his name is
joshua and he came in with a four
hundred ninety nine dollar donation
absolutely huge huge thank you to joshua
the four hundred ninety nine dollar perk
happens to be ten discounted one-year
memberships so now joshua has these ten
memberships to give away to people and
joshua's really a mensch because he has
read own ated the ten memberships back
to the show to give away at some point
in the future that's huge Pat I mean
Joshua is an all-star right now we're
gonna have to come up with some way to
give out those memberships we are going
to and there will be plenty of time for
that I assure you also donations as
small as one dollar 31 dollar donations
62 dollar donations for three dollar
donations it all matters even if you
think you shouldn't contribute because
you can't contribute much that is not
the right way to think about it if
everybody who can donate even just one
two or three dollars at david pakman.com
slash donate does it then this campaign
will be over before you know it so
please if you can donate more than 499
help to set a new high mark for a single
donation for the campaign but most
importantly help us to continue to grow
the number of donors it's currently at a
hundred and eighty-four donors let's get
to 250 that's the next target for me and
real quick two new perks that are
available only through the david pakman
show fundraiser are custom designed
t-shirts the first of which i'm showing
you on screen is the established in 2005
t-shirt we've determined that at the
show's inception in 2005 producer pat
was just two years old and 11
I'm sorry I keep forgetting this is an
exclusive t-shirt only available at
david pakman.com slash donate and for
the first time ever we have a hatred
male t-shirt we've taken one of the
dozen or so hey treat male graphics that
we use during hatred mail and turned it
into a t-shirt talk about a conversation
piece again the hatred male t-shirt and
the established in 2005 t-shirt both
only available at david pakman.com slash
donate